bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
locale nous sommes le jeudi 28 mai et
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui la 5e
réunion publique sur la ligne 18 agu
encours fait sal comomble avec plus de
400 personnes venues s'informer sur le
projet c'était hier soir mercredi marché
100 km pour dire non aux violences
sexuelles 31 villes des ivelines à
parcourir du 1er au 4 juin 2015
l'organisateur de ce rendez-vous nous en
dira plus en plateau et puis la région
Île-de-France renouvelle son engagement
financier envers les solid dayss la
manifestation organisée par Solidarité
Sida 800000 € de subvention pour cette
édition 2015 une conférence de presse
vient d'avoir lieu en présence d'une
partie des artistes engagés l'agence
crit Intérim soupçonné de s'être enrichi
frauduleusement en ne versant pas leurs
indemnités à des personnes qu'à
l'employé l'affaire est jugé aujourd'hui
est demain devant le tribunal
correctionnel de Paris l'antenne de
montinil Bretonneux figure parmi les 15
sites mis en accusation un code
informatique fruduleux aurait permis
cette opération cette fraude qui s'élève
à 2,8 millions de bénéfices au total
pour l'entreprise Grand Paris et la
ligne 18 qui doit relier dans plusieurs
années l'aéroport d'orli à
Versailles-Chantier en passant par
Saint-Quentin en Yveline avant l'enquête
publique qui va démarrer en janvier
prochain des réunions de concertation
sont organisées un peu partout ce
mercredi soir se déroulait à Guill en
cours 400 personnes y ont participé et
parmi lesquelles Catherine zulato et
Patrick Jacques de dixmud pour téfil une
salle comble 400 personnes pour mieux
comprendre les enjeux de la future ligne
18 du Grand Paris Express qui doit
relier Orly à Versailles chantier en
passant par 50 ans en Yveline les
interrogations sont nombreuses ça peut
nous intéresser oui ou oui on va habiter
qui en cours
donc donc c'est quelque chose qui qui
nous intéresse pour pour notre avenir
j'habite à vosan Bretonneux sur le site
de la Bretonnière donc qui a priori sera
juste en face de la gare donc je
voudrais savoir les impacts que ça
pourrait avoir deutre côté je suis pas
contre le projet je voudrais juste
savoir comment ça va figurer le quartier
la fonctionnalité est intéressante la la
liaison avec Orly c'est sûr que c'est un
plus bon aujourd'hui c'est vrai que en
regardant les photos parce que c'est
c'est là-dessus qu'on se rend compte du
passage effectif ça passe au-dessus d'un
des étant de la minunière et c'est quand
même un endroit qui est superbe la ligne
18 fait partie du grand Paris Express
une sorte de super métro automatique
autour de Paris à 50 ans en Yveline la
gare sera construite aux abords des
terrains talè près du Technocentre sur
le territoire de guillencour l'arrivée à
Saint-Quentin en iveline se fait en
souterrain hein le souterrain commence à
peu près au niveau du Golfe national et
puis on rentre en souterrain la gare
elle-même de Saint-Quentin il y aura
bien sûr une émergence un bâtiment
voyageur mais l'essentiel sera en
sous-terrain et ensuite on continue en
souous-terrain jusqu'à satori et jusqu'à
Versailles une partie en souous-terrain
sur 50 ans en Yveline par contre une
autre partie cette fois en aérien sur le
plateau de saclé il y a une option qui a
été prise qui fait un coup considérable
de différence en faisant l'option en
viaduc entre palzo et Saint-Quentin
c'est environ 1 milliard d'euros en
moins entre une version en souterrain
donc on a estimé que sur cette partie du
du tracé c'était tout à fait possible
nous allons mettre au travail des
équipes d'architectes à travers un
concours spécifique pour réaliser un
très beau viaduc une option dont ne veul
pas les maire de Manil et Amot et des
communes alentour une réunion est prévue
le 11 juin sur le secteur elle se promet
d'être rouleuse outre le viadux ce sont
également les question de viabilité
financière de l'opération et de
protection des terres agricoles qui sont
posé par les associations probablement
ça ne il y aura pas suffisamment de
trafic pour rendre la ligne rentable si
vous voulez bien sûr que tout le monde a
envie d'avoir un métro à côté de chez
lui le problème c'est qu'il faut qu'un
métro soit rentable et là ils vont faire
un métro à peu près identique à ce qu'il
y a dans Paris dans une zone qui est qui
est vraiment très peu dense à part
partir du moment où vous mettez un métro
sur un plateau agricole comme ça vous
avez qu'avoir les autres lignes de métro
qui ont été faites vous urbanisez tout
autour d'ailleurs c'est inscrit dans ce
drift hein les lignes de métro 500 m
autour des lignes de métro il faut faire
de la densification donc à terme pour
nous c'est c'est la mort du plateau
agricole l'enquête publique doit
démarrer en janvier le chantier devrait
prendre une dizaine d'années l'ensemble
du tracé du Grand Paris Express
représente un investissement de plus de
22 milliards d'euros le dossier complet
est consultable sur le site de la
Société du Grand
Paris une marche pour dire non aux
violences sexuelles au Congo c'est
l'initiative lancée par la gerbe une
association humanitaire chrétienne
bonsoir Jean-Marc soulin vous êtes le
directeur de l'opération baptisée
cyclotour 78 le point de départ de ce
projet République démocratique du Congo
un chiffre plus de 200000 femmes
victimes de viol de mutilation comme
arme de guerre depuis 1996 c'est ça le
le constat qu'on fait aujourd'hui et qui
vous pousse à à mener vos différentes
actions voilà et puis ce qui nous pousse
à mener les actions c'est un homme Tony
éongué qui qui est un gynécologue et qui
s'occupe de ses femmes qui les répare
qui est venu faire ses études en France
et qui avait des postes en France et qui
a fait le choix de retourner en
République démocratique du Congo puce
qu'il était attendu là-bas et on lui a
emmené du matériel il y a eu 7 tonnes de
matériel envoyé l'année dernière c'est
ça voilà c'est ça en container donc il
c'est arrivé en bateau puis ça a pris le
camion et ça s'est arrêté là où la route
s'arrête et ensuite c'est 225 km à pied
où les lits médicaux tout l'ensemble de
le chargement a été chargé sur des lits
et a été transporté dans la brousse en
poussant un vélo sur 225 km d'où la
symbolique de la marche qui va se tenir
à partir du du 1er juin juste par
rapport au matériel qui a été apporté
l'année dernière quel type de matériel
justement alors c'était beaucoup de
matériel médical principalement et puis
un petit peu de de vêtements aussi mais
principalement du matériel médical pour
et des panneaux solaires aussi pour ce
centre de santé il y a une vraie
situation d'urgence aujourd'hui en
République démocratique du Congo sur ces
violences sexuelles qui qui sont faites
aux femmes alors c'est vraiment une
problématique complètement d'actualité
avec chaque fois qu'il y a des
mouvements de de guerre un peu et de
guerilla c'est toujours utilisé comme
une arme de guerre et une femme qui qui
était violentée va être complètement
après exclue de de la société donc vous
intervenez là-bas à travers cet homme
que vous avez mentionné d'ailleurs il
sera à l'honneur à l'issue des 4 jours
de marche puisque il y aura un reportage
qui sera diffusé à versa et là aussi on
va y venir mais sur la marche comment ça
va s'organiser cette marche symbolique
on voulait mettre en valeur cet acte de
faire 225 km à pied donc on s'était
imaginé au début le faire faire la même
chose dans les zvelines en poussant un
vélo avec un lit médical et des
marchandises dessus euh donc on part des
queevillliis on monte jusqu'à versaill
on monte jusqu'à mont-elajolie puis on
passe à Oudan on descend à rambouillé et
on revient en passant par trappe sur
Versailles ça fait 130 km on s'est dit
que déjà c'était pas mal si on arrivait
à faire ça euh et on on va croiser comme
ça 31 communes et très souvent on est
reçu par par le maire par les élus on a
des élus qui ont fait le choix de de
nous accompagner jusqu'à la commune
suivante on a des parlementaires aussi
qui vont être là sur la marche et qui
vont nous accompagner et on invite en
fait chacun à marcher avec nous d'une
ville à une autre on'est pas obligé de
faire la totalité du parour sur pour les
plus les plus courageux mais on peut
rejoindre sur l'une des des étapes et
puis il y a un site Internet pour
connaître le tracé précis est-ce que ça
va permettre de récolter des fonds
également alors c'est c'est un souhait
aussi de faire connaître son travail
donc là spécialement aussi au niveau de
de la soirée à travers le le site
internet aussi on a trouvé une
entreprise partenaire donc c'est
l'entreprise à qui on a acheté les les
panneaux solaire qui qui en fait double
le don qui seront faits pendant les les
4 jours donc c'est aussi
intéressant du coup ça ça ça encourage
aussi pour cette opération là pendant
ces 4 jours on peut donner des livres
également qui sont revendus voilà alors
ça c'est une des particularités de
laassociation en fait on collecte des
livres euh et et on les revend et ce qui
permet de financer les les projets de
solidarité
internationale association justement
votre association qui qui œuvre existe
depuis quand comment elle s'est elle
s'est fondée parlez-nous un petit peu de
l'historique alors l'association elle a
plus de de 20 ans on est basé à é
queevilli donc dans les dans les
ivelines et il en est aussi ressourcerie
donc on collecte tout un tas de de
marchandises l'objectif c'est que tout
objet qui est encore utilisable au lieu
d'aller en déchetterie soit réemployé et
ensuite 70 % repart pour l'humanitaire
donc on travaille un petit peu donc avec
la RDC aussi avec le les pays de l'Est
Roumanie Bosnie Ukraine actuellement
avec le donbas notamment dans la zone de
guerre et et puis 30 % est revendu dans
un magasin type Emmaus qui sert à
financer les projets et l'ensemble de
l'activité sert en fait à réinsérer des
personnes puisquon est chantier
d'insertion et on a 16 personnes qui
travaillent sur l'activité dont qui vont
être salariés et l'objectif c'est qu'au
bout de 6 mois ils puissent retourner en
emploi en entreprise donc il y a
plusieurs actions qui sont menées il y a
pas voà c'est comment l'activité à
l'internationale en fait et comment on
pe aider au loin peut remettre en route
aussi des personnes sur place ici
l'association a 20 ans vous attendez
beaucoup de monde j'imagine sur le cycle
tour voilà il y aura des traversées de
ville à priori où il y aura beaucoup de
monde des parcours où il y aura
peut-être des grands moments de
solitude vous allez faire les 4 jours et
je vais faire les 4 jours vous êtes
préparé on s'entraîne un peu voilà
d'accord pour cette cette élan de de
solidarité à l'issue de ces 4 jours de
marche 4 juin 20h au conseil
départemental une soirée rep
autour justement de ce voilà donc il
aura un petit un petit film pour montrer
les 4 jours et les 31 communes passé et
vous pourrez vous revoir si vous avez
marché avec nous et puis et puis ensuite
la présentation du travail fabuleux que
fait ce ce médecin l'écho qui du travail
qui est fait par ce médecin justement
est-ce qu'il a un appui il y a votre
association qui l'aide mais est-ce que
il y a d'autres appuis d'autres
associations et même dans son pays
est-ce que aujourd'hui il est connu
reconnu aidé alors il est connu et
reconnu puisqu'il gère une zone de santé
qui est plus grande que l'île-de France
et c'est le seul spécialiste donc les
personnes font des fois 300 km à pied
pour venir être opéré par ce docteur
c'est très très impressionnant il est
reconnu au niveau de de l'État en fait
puisqu'il est représentant de du centre
de santé sur la sur la région voilà en
France pas encore connu mais on espère
que qu' va bientôt l'être est-ce que vos
bénévoles vous-même vous allez sur place
pour voir justement le travail qui est
mené rencontrer ces personnes voilà donc
là on a une une personne qui en revient
tout juste et qui qui fera aussi objet
de de cette présentation euh au conseil
départementalil départemental
aujourd'hui le travail qui qu' mène
qu'il mène sur place c'est une première
une telle opération pour pour
l'association voilà c'est une première
on voilà on est très c'est né un peu
comme ça c'est surtout en voyant le
contrendu de cette mission qu'on a pensé
que c'était vraiment important de de
mettre un peu sous les feux des
projecteurs le courage de ces gens
capables de faire 225 km à pied
plusieurs fois parce que quand ils
arrivent sur place ils remontent sur le
vélo qui est libre ils rentent en vélo
et puis recharge le vélo et repart à
pied en le poussant c'est vraiment
impressionnant en fait ce qui permet
d'acheminer le matériel comme en 2014 le
matériel que vous aviez apporté les les
7 tonnes aujourd'hui au niveau de la
collecte et que est-ce qu'une opération
de même envergure est prévue pour voilà
tout à fait on est en train de préparer
un un prochain container qui partira la
fin de fin de
l'annéeanné les 7 tonnes de matériel
seront sont battu
vous allez battre leur corps voilà on va
voir on est encore en train de chercher
mais du coup la marche nous a fait
prendre aussi beaucoup de contact avec
les hôpitaux les médecins les centres de
santé qui du coup s'intéressent et voilà
ça permet j'en profit quel matériel vous
manque aujourd'hui parce que il faut
autant passer le message sur le plateau
voilà alors on est sur du matériel
simple en fait euh mais donc des lit
médicaux on est sur les échographes
aussi ça c'est un peu plus lourd mais
c'est vraiment très très rechercher
voilà et puis après aussi tout ce qui va
être fourniture médicale
euh qu'on peut qu'on peut emporter et
puis vous pouvez faire des dons aussi si
vous ne pouvez pas participer à ces 4
jours de marche ou à ce rendez-vous du 4
juin à 20h en conseil départemental il y
a un site internet pour faire les dons
tout simplement puisque c'est une ONG
donc le le travail est reconnu
déductible VO déduction fiscale c'est
toujours bon de le rappeler une dernière
question les horaires de passage enfin
le les moments importants pour ceux qui
viennent vous rejoindre sur les 4 jours
alors le départ àcvi le lundi matin 1er
juin à 9h rendez-vous à 9h ça c'est le
lancement et puis après ici dans dans le
secteur on sera le le 4 en fait à
hlencour départ à 9h d'élencour le 4
puis 10h à trappe 11h à montinil
broteneux euh 12h devant le centre
commercial et puis ensuite on part sur
Buc et Versailles à 16h vous faites des
pauses au milieu de tout ça il y aura
pas de pause donc soyez soyez sportifs
soyez motivés en tout cas merci
Jean-Marc soulin d'êtreevenenu sur ce
plateau cyclotour dès le 1er juin
renseignement parcours détaillés sur le
site internet qui s'est affiché merci à
vous merci beaucoup votre opération de
solidarité c'est solidis ce sera du 26
au 28 juin à parislonchamp chaque année
les recettes du festival permettent
d'accompagner de soutenir les malades et
leurs familles dans plus de 20 pays la
région Île-deFrance soutient
financièrement ce rendez-vous depuis 16
ans une conférence de presse vient de se
tenir à Paris en présence des artistes
engagés et nous y
étions solid days 300 artistes 80
concerts sur 3 jours des centaines de
bénévoles et d'associations des milliers
de visiteurs pour un combat contre une
maladie qui touche plus de 35 millions
de personnes dans le monde les sponsors
aussi sont nombreux premiers d'entre eux
la région qui verse cette année 800000 €
l'Île-de-France qui ne s'imagine pas
manquer ce rendez-vous à l'hippodrome de
long je pense que ça serait faillir à
notre vocation nous nous avons une
charte ici à la région pour lutter
contre toutes les discrimination et
celle-là est sûrement une des plus
pénibles une des plus épouvantables qui
puisse intervenir dans la vie d'une
d'une femme ou d'un homme quand vous
achetez un billet pour solidz vous aidez
à la fois solidaa dans son
accompagnement de famillees migrantes à
bobini Marseille
ou ou Montreuil pour leur donner accès à
à des besoins de première nécessité donc
on est en train de parler d'alimentaire
d'hygiène
d'hébergement vous aidez une association
au fin fond de la République
centrafricaine qui accompagnent des
orphelins du SIDAS ou des familles ou
des femmes isolées en 16 éditions solid
days a permis de récolter quelques 21
millions d'euros pour mener à bien ces
différentes opérations mais l'enjeu
majeur c'est aussi la prévention en
France une personne se contamine toutes
les heures et demi et l'utilisation des
préservatifs ne cesse de diminuer les
porte-paroes de solidarité ne cessent
eux de rabâer le même discours j'ai
envie de dire combien de fois on a
entendu met ton mets ton bonnet mets ton
écharpe tuas mise la veste mets tes
chaussures tu pas là on dit bonjour on
dit merci sois poli s'il te plaît
combien de fois on l' entendu c'est
comme ça tous les
jours pour que les gens comprennent
après c'est vrai que il y a y a beaucoup
de générations qui sont né avec
donc ce qui est VI là-dedans c'est que
si on si on répète pas comme tu disais
en permanence le fait d'être né avec ça
devient un petit peu banal c'est comme
avec le téléphone
génération qui sont n avec
[Musique]
naturam engagé sur le festival depuis
plusieurs années un groupe militant qui
n'hésite pas à rappeler l'importance de
ces rendez-vous culturel parfois menac
et pourant fédérateur et qui permett de
faire passer des
messes mise en cause cette année
globalement sur la culture aujourd'hui
dans ce pays-là euh l'investissement
privé très rare contrairement à nos
voisins allemands ou ou anglais le
Messina est très rare donc du coup s'il
y a pas le soutien des des des des
pouvoirs publics il y a pas de culture
on va se retrouver l'année prochaine
avec des festivals qui vont disparaître
parce qu'ils ont pas beaucoup vont pas
réussir à boucler les budgets et ça par
contre ça c'est pour moi c'est
gravissimeamatique solid days n'est pour
l'instant pas menacé même si pour les HE
organisateur le financement n'est pas
toujours évident moi mon boulot en tant
que directeur fondateur de solidaritc
c'est qu'entre septembre et avril
j'assure avec d'autres le montage
financier du festival il faut se battre
notamment dans une période comme celle
actuelle où l'État a moins d'argent
beaucoup d'entreprise privées
connaissent des difficultés que le thème
du sida est moins porteur qu'il y a
quelques années et donc à un moment il
faut toujours se renouveler travailler
convaincre le renouvellement c'est
également le mot d'ordre de la
programmation avec Angus et Julia Stone
shinesman ou encore
révélation du public en 2011 au Victoire
de la
[Musique]
musique des gens veulent venir nous voir
en concert se sensibilise sur ce sujet
là c'est déjà ch on aura déjà pas servi
à rien et ce sera pas mal on a la chance
qu'on nous écoute donc autantant dire
des trucs pas trop pas trop bêt et entre
deux concerts le public pourra également
découvrir en avant-première le dernier
film de Liv Linois yanarus Bertrand 5
ans après home human se veut un projet
dédié au genre humain je pense que
solidz porte un peu les valeurs que nous
on porte dans ce film human c'est pour
ça qu'on est content d'en montrer
quelques quelques petits morceaux voilà
tout petit morceau ce film fait 3h 8
donc on pourra pas tout montrer mais
c'est des petits morceaux d'interview on
a tourné nous à solidz partie du film il
y a beaucoup d'amour à solidz qu il y a
beaucoup de l'impression donc ce film
bien av bien sa place
là-bas demandz un programme noubliez pas
pas de prendre le programme c'est très
important 50 pages de
pbolire solidis coup d'envoi dans un
mois il reste encore quelques places
mais il faudra faire vite pour être de
la
fite ce jeudi 17e journée nationale de
prévention et de dépistage des cancers
de la peau lever le doute sur un grain
de beauté inquiétant questionner un
dermatologue à 5quen ans en yeline des
dépistages gratuits anonymes était
proposé à l'Institut de promotion de la
la santé l'IPS à noté qu'en France les
mélanomes cutanées ont triplé en 25 ans
une une dermatologue nous a décrit les
signes qui doivent
alertereur ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'
il a changé il grossit il devient moins
régulier dans ses
contour il peut avoir plusieurs couleurs
au lieu d'une seule et puis devenir un
petit peu en relief alors qu'il était
plat au par avant c'est vrai qu'on
remarque qu'il y a une augmentation des
cancers de la peau les gens s'exposant
davantage au soleil
donc on on recommande toujours de mettre
de l'écran de ne pas aller aux heures où
il fait trop chaud enfin de faire
attention et faites-vous bien attention
à protéger votre peau du soleil vos
conseils c'est notre question du jour je
mets de la crème solaire je m'expose pas
trop entre MIDH et MH et 14h B je vais
des lettes de soleil déjà puis je me
mets de la crèmei ça m'arrive des fois
aussi attraper des coups de soleil parce
que des fois j'oublie moi je me protège
je mettre l'écran total sur le visage
particulièrement toujours un chapeau
aussi même quand je fais du jardin un
chapeau de soleil bah surtout quand on a
des enfants donc on évite d'y aller
entre MIDH et 2 quoi on y va plutôt en
fin de journée on essaie de se mettre à
l'abri crème solaire ou quand on va à la
plage mais bon région parisienne on est
pas trop on n'est pas trop impacté par
tout ce qui est dangerosité du soleil je
trouve il y a tellement le nuage de
pollution au dessus qu'on est un peu
protégé je prends des produits pour me
préger à plus de 5 ans c'est surtout que
j'ai je pense que il faut quand même
faire attention pour pas avoir des
mélanomes donc je protège mes petits
enfants enfin tout mon entourage voilà
comme une mamie responsable sport le
vélodrome de 5 ans neline a inauguré sa
nouvelle piste de BMX elle est désormais
plus rapide plus technique et surtout
moins dangereuse le parcours devrait
être inscrit au programme des Jeux
Olympiques 2024 si la candidature de la
France est retenue le reportage est
signé Michel elmidoro et lodim moine
pour les images une inauguration en
grande pompe la nouvelle piste du
Stadium BMX a officiellement été
présentée au public ce mercredi livré
une première fois en janvier 2014 le
tracé a subi de profondes modifications
pour répondre au mieux aux exigences du
haut niveau on commence par une butte de
départ à 8 m de haut donc qui est le
format standard olympique où les
athlètes passent de 0 à 60 kmh donc vous
voyez ça fait une grosse accélération en
de en 2 secondes à peine après une
première ligne droite avec avec des gros
obstacles de des des sauts de 12 à 14 m
de long trois virages quatre lignes
droitees au total et où bah les les
obstacles je dirais les bosses
s'enchaînent elle est super rapide c'est
rien à voir à ce qu'il y avait avant
elle a été refaite à neuve elle est
vraiment adaptée à l'entraînement pour
s'entraîner au mieux pour être prêt pour
pour les compétitions elle se rapproche
au maximum de ce qu'on se trouve de ce
qu'on retrouve en Coupe du monde donc
c'est parfait cette piste couverte de
450 m est surtout moins dangereuse que
la précédente de nombreux accidents
avaient été recensés sur l'ancien tracé
elle est tout aussi exigante vu sportif
mais on a enlevé de la dangerosité
complètement inutile comme bah
finalement un revêtement complètement
glissant et puis des appels sur des boss
qui étaient pas forcément idéaux au
total le projet a coûtait 110000 € près
de la moitié du dossier a été prise en
charge par la Communauté d'Agglomération
de 50 an en Yveline lorsque on veut
accueillir de grandes compétitions il
est bien évident qu'il faut avoir des
structures comme celle-ci on est très
heureux parce que c'est une structure
très rare même de parl monde don ce
stade de BMX couvert nous permet déjà de
pouvoir accueillir toutes les grandes
compétitions internationales et donc on
on en est très heureux cette nouvelle
piste devrait accueillir les épreuves de
BMX pendant les Jeux Olympiques 2024 si
la France est sélectionné par le Comité
international olympique cette nouvelle
enceinte pourrait faire pencher la
balance du côté de la candidature
française une cure de jouvance également
pour le golf de Saint-Quentin en Eveline
le Golf National la rénovation du du
centre de Loiselet vient de se terminer
une structure qui permettra notamment
aux joueurs professionnels de
s'entraîner pendant la rider Cup de
2018 le Golf National de 50 ans niveline
fait peau neuve à un mois du début de
l'Open de France la rénovation du centre
de loiselé vient de se terminer dans la
partie est du golf et là a été refait
l'ensemble des bâtiments les toitures
misiseorme des installations privatives
derrière
réouverture de la boutique accueil et
l'ensemble du restaurant le centre est
ouvert toute l'année aux habitués du
site débutant comme professionnel la
structure sera également utilisée
pendant les grandes compétitions comme
l'Open de France ou la rider Cup
2018 nous en avions besoin ça correspond
également à l'élévation du niveau
golfique en vue de la rider Cup 2018 au
niveau de l' Wesley où nous sommes il
faut que le golfeur se sente chez lui
que tout soit à sa disposition à sa
portée et qu' se sente le bienvenu chez
nous c'est ce que nous voulons faire et
je crois qu'on a réussi coou total de ce
lifting 600000 € entièrement financé par
la Fédération Française de
Golf quelques images à présent d'Alain
ducass le chef étoilé il s'approvisionne
entièrement pour son restaurant Le
Plazza Athéné à Paris en fruits et en
légumes bio au potager de la reine au
château de Versailles le chef men du
château a permis la remise en
exploitation du jardin parmi les
produits cultivés dans cette enceinte
des pommes de terre de noir Moutier dont
c'était la première récolte hier
mercredi
oui c'est le potager restant en
exclusivité j'ai une passion pour les la
PR de noir Moutier depuis longtemps donc
c'est pas nouveau donc d'accord oui les
dire tiens on va on va la planter parce
que cette terre est très beau nous dit
la terre est extraordinaire mais c'est
vrai qu'elle nous donne aigu
extraordinaire c'est bien qu'elle est
elle est pas sur sollicité les animaux
en dessous font leur travail il y a pas
de pesticides il y a pas de traitement
il y a pas d'engré l'intégralité de cet
entretien retrouveré dans le prochain
vyp sur TVfil 78 c'est la fin de ce
journal demain vendredi Caine zulato
pour l'essentiel du jour le résumé de la
semaine également tout de suite filch
avec Floren
[Musique]
parfait